it was the moment his supporters had
dreaded
you're not taking him off this farm
you're not taking him live
the police arrived in force it was
totally disproportionate
with jeffrey officials they were
determined to carry out that this
heinous crime you know
there was no way that geronimo had tb
for years a healthy happy animal on this
farm
they had spent weeks camping by his side
after years of legal battles but in the
end it was the courts that won
i just hate bullies and the government
been bullying this poor family and
there's paul alpaca the alpaca hasn't
got tb simple as that
the alpaca tested positive for tb back
in 2017 but supporters had always
insisted that he was healthy
geronimo attracted international media
interest but for his owner and
supporters it was always about more than
just one alpaca it was in their words
about a flawed testing system
george uses an absolute disgrace
for geronimo's owner a day of anger
farmers have to lose cattle all the time
because of poor tb policy and because
the tests aren't good enough but what
they did to him was create a suspicion
of disease deliberately that is not the
same thing farmers are going through
what i'm going through all the time but
they haven't had a crime committed
against them
the government insists they had no
choice but to put him down it's very sad
to see
any animal
have to be put down in this manner but
it is really important that we uphold
rules to keep tb at bay in this country
because that's the way we protect many
many more animals and livestock across
the country
petitions and even a march on downing
street could not save geronimo
the question now is did he have tb when
he was put to sleep
a postmortem examination
may hold the answer
dan whitehead sky news in
gloucestershire